ACCOUNTABLE TO A PENDING RUSSIAN
OIL PRICE CAP.
>> Bret: JACKIE, THANKS, LET’S
BRING IN DAVID PREECE, AT THE
NATIONAL SECURITY WEBSITE LAW
FAIR, ALSO A FORMER INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER AT THE CIA.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> YOU BET.
>> Bret: HOW DO YOU SEE THIS
PLAYING OUT RIGHT NOW WITH WHAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS SAYING AND
DOING?
>> IT’S REALLY INTERESTING TO
WATCH HOW THIS SHIFT HAS
HAPPENED WITH THE ESCALATION
THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN IS NOW
INVOLVED IN.
HE THINKS THAT HE IS GOING TO
EVEN NOW SOMEHOW GET THE
UKRAINIANS TO SUBMIT.
IF I FIRE A FEW MORE MISSILES AT
A FEW MORE SENATORS, THAT WILL
KNOCK OUT THE WILL TO FIGHT.
AND THAT’S NOT WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN.
I IMAGINE IN MY FORMER
COLLEAGUES AT THE CIA ARE
PRESENTING INTELLIGENCE TO THE
PRESIDENT AND OTHERS IN THE
GOVERNMENT SAYING UKRAINIAN WILL
TO FIGHT A STRONG AND EVERY TIME
THE RUSSIANS HAVE ESCALATED WHEN
THEY GO AFTER CIVILIAN TARGETS
IT ACTUALLY INCREASES THE
UKRAINIANS WILL TO FIGHT AND IT
MAKES THEM WANT TO SEE THIS
THING THROUGH TILL THE END EVEN
IF IT INVOLVES SIGNIFICANT LOSS
OF LIFE IN THE FUTURE.
>> Bret: EVEN IF THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE U.S. THAT
WOULD LIKE THE UKRAINIANS TO GET
TO THE TABLE EVENTUALLY, TO
NEGOTIATE SOMETHING, THAT GETS
US AWAY FROM THIS VERY TENSE
MOMENT.
>> YES, REALLY HARD TO GO TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE IF YOU ARE
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE THE RUSSIANS HAVE NOT
ONLY BRUTALIZE YOUR PEOPLE, BUT
ARE HOLDING ON TO SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF UKRAINIAN TERRITORY,
THAT’S NOT A GOOD TIME TO GO,
HENCE WE SEE THE VERY STRONG
COUNTER DEFENSIVE OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS, UKRAINIANS MOVING
TO A POSITION WHERE
VLADIMIR PUTIN WILL HAVE SOME
TOUGH CHOICES TO MAKE ABOUT WHAT
IS HE ACTUALLY GOING TO DO TO
ESCALATE IF AT ALL, OR IS HE
GOING TO PULL OUT OF SOME OF
THESE AREAS TO ENABLE SOME
FACE-SAVING MEASURE ON HIS OWN
PART.
FRANKLY, I’M NOT SEEING IT YET.
HE SEEMS TO BE ESCALATING THE
RHETORIC JUST THE SAME AS THEY
ESCALATE THE BATTLE FIELD
ACTIVITY, BUT THAT’S WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR.
>> Bret: LET’S TALK ABOUT
ANOTHER ISSUE OF RUSSIA, DEALING
WITH RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE, AND
OCTOBER, DAYS BEFORE THE 2020
ELECTION, YOU SIGN ONTO THIS
OPEN LETTER THAT WAS PUBLISHED
BY POLITICO AND SAID WE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO SAY THAT THE ARRIVAL IN
THE U.S. SEEN BELONG TO THE
VICE PRESIDENT SON HUNTER, MUCH
OF IT RELATED TO THE TOP SERVING
ON THE BOARD OF THE UKRAINIAN
GAS COMPANY HAS ALL THE CLASSIC
EARMARKS OF A RUSSIAN
INFORMATION OPERATION.
WHY DID YOU SIGN ONTO THAT?
>> BECAUSE OF WHAT IT SAYS.
IT IS ALL OF THE CLASSIC
EARMARKS OF ONE OF THESE
OPERATIONS.
YOU WILL NOTE ELSEWHERE IN THE
LETTER THAT IT ALSO SAYS WE
DON’T KNOW IF THIS IS A RUSSIAN
OPERATION AT ALL.
THAT HAS BEEN DRAMATICALLY
CHANGED IN THE RETELLING OF THE
STORY, BUT THE LETTER IS MERELY
POINTING OUT SO THAT THIS IS THE
KIND OF THING THAT TIME AFTER
TIME AFTER TIME PEOPLE WHO STUDY
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION AND LOOK
AT OTHER TACTICS AFTER THE LONG
PERIOD OF TIME, THIS IS THE KIND
OF THING THAT THEY LIKE TO
AMPLIFY JUST THROUGH THE DISCORD
WITHIN TARGET COUNTRIES.
SOMETIMES THAT TARGET COUNTRY AS
THE UNITED STATES, MOST OFTEN IT
WAS EUROPE, BUT THE TACTIC IS AN
OLD ONE, A TRIED-AND-TRUE ONE,
AND SUCCESSFUL.
>> Bret: IN THIS CASE IT WAS
NOT TRUE, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
FOUND THAT TO THAT THESE ARE
AUTHENTICATED, THE RUSSIAN POST
THOUSANDS OF EMAILS FROM THE
LAPTOP COMPUTER OF HUNTER BIDEN
ARE AUTHENTIC COMMUNICATIONS
THAT CAN BE VERIFIED THROUGH
CRYPTOGRAPHIC SIGNATURES THROUGH
GOOGLE AND OTHER TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES SAYING TWO SECURITY
EXPERTS EXAMINE THE DATA COME IN
"THE NEW YORK POST" THAT DID THE
STORY FIRST SAYS HOLY COW, HERE
ARE THESE OTHER VERIFICATIONS
AND THEN IN THE DEBATE, RIGHT
BEFORE THE ELECTION, NOW
PRESIDENT BIDEN USE IT, TAKE A
LISTEN.
>> RECKLESS, ABSOLUTELY
RECKLESS, HE HEARD THIS, THE
ALLY AND FRIENDS HEARD THIS,
IT’S TRUE.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
ISSUE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT RACE RIGHT NOW AND I DO
WANT TO STAY ON THE ISSUE OF
RACE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP --
>> I DON’T HAVE TO RESPOND TO
THAT, THERE ARE 50 FORMER
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
WHO SAID THAT WHAT HE IS
ACCUSING ME OF IS A RUSSIAN
PLANS, IF YOU MEAN THE LAPTOP IS
NOW ANOTHER RUSSIA-RUSSIA-RUSSIA
HOAX?
>> THIS IS WHERE HE IS GOING.
>> Bret: SO UNDERSTANDING HOW
YOU CHARACTERIZE IT, BUT HE
CHARACTERIZED IT DIFFERENTLY AND
USED IT IN THE DEBATE JUST DAYS
BEFORE AN ELECTION.
>> I WILL LET PRESIDENT BIDEN
SPEAK FOR HIMSELF, HE IS CAPABLE
OF DOING THAT, WHAT I WILL SAY
IS THAT IT HAS ALL OF THE
CLASSIC EARMARKS OF A RUSSIAN
CAMPAIGN IN THE WAY THAT IT WAS
DISSEMINATED AND PROPAGATED
THROUGH MEDIA.
>> Bret: DO YOU REGRET SIGNING
ONTO THE LETTER?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
ALL OF THE EARMARKS.
>> Bret: ABSOLUTELY NOT.
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS NOT TRUE, IT
HAD THE EARMARKS, BUT IT WAS NOT
TRUE.
>> WHAT IS NOT TRUE?
>> Bret: THAT IT WAS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
>> HE SAID THAT WE DO NOT KNOW
IF THIS IS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
>> Bret: IT HAS ALL THE
CLASSIC EARMARKS OF A RUSSIAN
OPERATION.
>> DATE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AN
INFORMATION AND IT
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
IN A MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN, IT
IS NOT MY FAULT IF PEOPLE DON’T
LOOK UP DEFINITIONS.
>> Bret: THE PURPOSE OF THE
LETTER IS TO HAVE AN EFFECT ON
THE NUANCE YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
NEVER MADE IT TO CANDIDATES BY
THEN, BECAUSE HE SAID IT PLAINLY
ON A DEBATE STAGE THAT OBVIOUSLY
AFFECTED THE DYNAMIC.
DON’T YOU THINK?
>> I WOULD ABSOLUTELY LOVE FOR
ALL NEWS MEDIA TO SHOW THE NEWS
MEDIA, SOME NEWS MEDIA WITH THE
SOUND BITES, THAT’S NOT HELPFUL
TO FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
INSTEAD OF QUOTING ONE SENTENCE,
PEOPLE ACTUALLY READ AN ENTIRE
PARAGRAPH SHOWS THAT WE DON’T
KNOW IF IT IS RUSSIA.
I DON’T KNOW IF IT AFFECTED
ANYTHING, WE DON’T ANALYZE THE
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENTS.
WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS POINT OUT
THAT THIS HAS ALL THE CLASSIC
EARMARKS OF A RUSSIAN
INFORMATION CAMPAIGN, NOT TO SAY
THAT IT IS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION BUT TO SAY THAT
THE PROPAGATION THROUGH AMERICAN
MEDIA AND INTERNATIONAL MEDIA
HAS ALL OF THE EARMARKS OF A
RUSSIAN INFORMATION CAMPAIGN
BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN IT OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THEY LOVE TO SEW THESE KIND OF
DIVISIONS AND EXACERBATE THEM,
THAT IS NOT AMERICAN, THAT IS
RUSSIAN.
>> Bret: I GOT YOU, BUT IT WAS
A JOE BIDEN CAMPAIGN BECAUSE HE
USED IT IN THE CAMPAIGN AND IN